the movie opens up as a mysterious
spacecraft crashes into a lake in Seoul
Korea and appears to have come from a
different galaxy after a while a person
without clothes slowly emerges and heads
to the city in the next scene we are
introduced to a couple who just got
married and are deeply in love with one
another the husband man Gill is a
hard-working and intelligent man who
does all the housework even though he
has an extremely packed schedule on the
other hand his wife so he is always busy
chatting with her friends and shopping
she considers herself the luckiest woman
in the world later that evening she
attends a high school reunion an event
which they have eagerly anticipated for
three years one of her classmates named
Yang Sun whose dream is to be an actress
has an embarrassing entrance as she
slips and falls down the stairs however
she hides her embarrassment claiming
that she deliberately did it to practice
for her upcoming action movies as the as
the conversation unfolds among the
school friends Yang Sun asks sohi about
her marital life our protagonist this
girl responds in a positive way
describing her husband as an attractive
intelligent and dedicated individual who
owns a Pharma company a few moments
later the group starts talking about
their old classmates Sarah who
apparently spent time in jail after
murdering her husband why did she do it
she allegedly caught him cheating on her
with other women after the reunion party
so he arrives home late and finds her
husband fast asleep as she approaches
him she notices a missed call on his
phone from an unidentified person on
checking further she discovers various
messages including one that mentions an
upcoming meeting with man Gill on Friday
as expected this worries so he and she
starts suspecting that her husband might
be having a secret affair outside to
confirm her doubts she Googles the
symptoms of a person who is having an
extramarital affair one of the websites
claims that these people will always
make excuses saying that they are
working overtime when so he reads this
she is dejected as mangle gave her the
same excuse earlier my husband works
extra hours to pay for my lavish
lifestyle I should kill him the next
morning she deliberately asks man Gill
about his plans for Friday inviting him
to a married couple's get-together
however he refuses pretending to have a
funeral to attend in order to support
his lie he claims that the doctor
predicted the death of one of his
friends on that exact Friday upon
hearing this response so he's doubts
almost transform into certainty but
still to confirm her suspicions she
seeks the assistance of a detective
named Dr Jang she pays him a good
amounts and asks him to keep a close eye
on her husband in the next scene Dr Jang
embarks on his mission to tail man Gill
and monitor his activities after closely
observing him for an entire day he meets
so he and shares all of his discoveries
with her he reveals that man Gill first
visited a golf course and then spent a
two-hour non-stop workout session at the
gym but everywhere he went he was
surrounded by women Dr Jango is on to
claim that man Gill has multiple women
in his life excluding so he shockingly
he possesses three different marriage
certificates of apart from hers and all
of his previous wives are either missing
or deceased the most bizarre detail is
that he saw man Gill at a gas station
where he drank gasoline worth thirty
dollars all this information is too much
for so he's innocent brain to process so
she simply storms away from there that
night she contemplates stabbing her
husband while he is asleep but soon
Retreats feeling helpless so he decides
to confide in her friend Sarah and even
expresses her desire to have her husband
killed upon hearing her story Sarah who
is also experienced four divorces in the
past tells her that a perfect husband
does not exist she also reveals that the
rumor about her killing her own husband
is untrue but says that he deserved to
die for his actions meanwhile back at
home man Gill is secretly poisoning the
water with the intention of executing
his wife the following day so he pays a
visit to Dr jang's office during their
conversation the latter begins to
suspect that man Gill may not be a
normal human and so he doesn't
understand he shows her a book called
unbreakable and assumes that her husband
is a mutant species from another planet
Dr Jang is on point according to Dr Jang
he has encountered similar cases in the
past but all of his clients from those
cases have either vanished or met
unfortunate ends however so he finds it
difficult to accept that her husband is
an alien so in order to persuade her Dr
Jang takes her to a gas station where
she witnesses her husband gulping down
liters of gasoline leaving her utterly
astonished the things rich people do for
entertainment on the other hand the
Extraterrestrial life-form quarantine
Center XCOM arranges a secret meeting
that is attended by space scientists
government officials and detective
officers the primary objective of this
Gathering is to capture the aliens who
seem to be collecting human DNA and
spreading viruses among the human
population and as part of their plan's
initial phase they intend to Target man
gill who is believed to be a leader
among the alien group back at home so he
retrieves a water bottle from the
refrigerator unaware that it is the same
one that man Gill had previously laced
with poison and as soon as she drinks
the water she collapses to the ground
witnessing this mangel rushes to her
side feigning concern for her well-being
but as soon as she loses Consciousness
he contacts his alien companions
informing them that he has successfully
executed his mission
later so he is admitted to the hospital
where the doctor delivers the sorrowful
news of her demise her friends from
school who are also present at the
hospital mourn her untimely death
moments later Sarah also arrives and
upon learning of the tragic news she
holds man Gill responsible she begins
assaulting him physically while hurling
different curse words at him as all of
this is happening so he suddenly regains
Consciousness and spits out the poison
she had consumed earlier this obviously
shocks man Gill but he pretends to be
happy on the following day he visits a
drugstore owned by one of his aliens
Associates in order to purchase a more
potent poison but unbeknownst to him the
detectives have been closely monitoring
his activities later that night man Gill
engages in a phone call with his fellow
aliens discussing their plan to
eliminate sohi and dispose of her body
he smirks saying that today is his
birthday and he wants to celebrate by
turning it into sohi's death day
elsewhere so he seeks assistance from
Sarah and Dr Jang to take care of her
husband after being discharged from the
hospital the trio devises a scheme to
use electric current and kill man Gill
Dr Jang has also created an antidote
against the aliens which he plans to
inject into mangil if their initial
strategy fails following this the three
of them arrive at sohi's residence and
begin setting up the Trap Dr Jang
inserts an electrical line into the
bathtub and connects its switch to a
remote control that resembles a typical
lighter just as they finish the setup
the doorbell rings believing it to be
man Gill Sarah and Dr Jan quickly hide
inside the bathroom while so he answers
the door unexpectedly Yang's son is
standing on the other side with a gun
she is looking for her boyfriend who
turns out to be none other than Dr Jang
it is revealed that she received a
message from an unidentified number
informing her of her boyfriend's
infidelity Yang's son proceeds to search
the entire house and soon assumes that
her boyfriend is hiding in the bathroom
as a result she forcefully breaks into
the bathroom only to find Sarah taking a
dump the two stared at each other for a
while before Yang's son awkwardly
apologizes and leaves but unbeknownst to
her Dr Jang is inside the bathtub hidden
behind the curtain back in the living
room Yang Sun decides to light a
cigarette to calm herself down she picks
up the same remote control lighter and
presses its button inadvertently causing
Dr Jang to be electrocuted and killed
hearing the loud bang the three girls
rushed to the bathroom and start
panicking they fear that they will be
caught by the police so Sarah suggests
that they hide the body in the closet
but as they are doing so mangil suddenly
arrives home adding to their problems
fortunately so he manages to persuade
him to take a shower first buying them
some time and while the alien lies in
the bathtub enjoying music she seizes
the perfect opportunity and presses the
button electrocuting him the girls then
slowly open the bathroom door to check
on him but to their astonishment mangel
is still alive in a quick response they
pretend that it was a surprise birthday
celebration for him later as the
celebrations are in full swing so he
requests him to drink some wine she had
secretly poisoned moments earlier man
Gill agrees without any hesitation and
consumes it but he remains unhappy
shortly afterward a phone rings from the
closet and mangil suspects that someone
is broken into their house he carefully
goes to the room and opens the closet
only to find Dr Jang lying there
surprisingly the doctor opens his eyes
revealing that he is still alive but
mangel who believes that he is an
intruder swiftly knocks him unconscious
again in order to hide their crime the
three girls cleverly suggest that man
Gill bury the dead body but just as they
are preparing to leave man Gill's alien
accomplices arrive at their doorstep
intending to assist him in disposing of
sohi's body as planned however since
their initial scheme didn't go as
expected they feign a surprise party
celebration for man Gill he invites them
inside to have drinks and asks them to
wait until they return mangel and the
three girls then make their way to a
nearby Forest to bury Dr Jang later
while man Gill is digging the grave so
he strikes him with a shovel rendering
him unconscious the girls then hurriedly
start burying the two bodies together
but to their dismay the alien suddenly
pops his head out of the ground
showcasing that he is indestructible in
a state of panic the girls run towards
their car before driving away but the
stubborn alien starts pursuing them with
his superhuman abilities and eventually
catches up to them in the end the car
collides with a rock causing man Gill to
fall down a hill but as for the girls
they are left completely unharmed in the
next scene the trio returns to sohi's
place only to discover that man Gill's
friends have died from The Poisoned wine
left with no other option they load the
bodies into their vehicle with the
intention of burying them as well but as
they drive towards the forest they are
stopped at a checkpoint by police
officers who soon find out that they are
drinking in a drunk State I mean driving
as a result they are taken to the police
station shortly thereafter Dr Jang is
brought to the same station it turns out
he has survived once again but has lost
all of his memories after the electric
shock the police believe that he is a
homeless man who cannot speak meanwhile
man Gill is also revealed to be alive
and he climbs up the hill to find
himself in a random house there he finds
multiple containers filled with fuel
moments after he consumes them his
injuries miraculously heal restoring his
health he then proceeds to the police
station and borrows a phone to call sohi
when he hears the phone ringing nearby
he discovers the three girls hiding
behind him mangel quickly seizes the
opportunity and bails them out claiming
that they are his friends he also takes
Dr Jang promising to drop him off at the
nearest shelter after they depart from
the police station mangil Reveals His
True Form and intends to kill so he and
her friends in a state of fear Sarah
brings out a knife to stab his head but
it still has no effect on the alien the
chaos causes their vehicle to slide down
a cliff and flip thankfully the girls
managed to escape with just some minor
injuries they then flee the scene and
the alien starts following them shortly
after the detectives from XCOM arrive at
the crash site and commence a search for
mangel among the wreckage they
discovered Dr Jang and take him with
them May meanwhile the girls seek refuge
in an abandoned building to save
themselves from the alien but man Gill
has an extraordinary smelling capability
enabling him to track them down easily
just as he is about to kill so he the
x-com detectives arrive at the scene a
fierce battle ensues between the two
parties but man Gill with his Superior
Powers defeats the officers one after
another in the midst of the chaos the
three girls managed to slip away from
the building and head to the detective's
car where they discover Jang the doctor
appears to have regained some of his
lost memories so he presents them with
an antidote he developed against the
aliens wasting no time so he bravely
administers the antidote into man Gill's
body from behind which ultimately causes
him to die finally ending the intense
situation the scene then shifts to one
year later and we see so he Sarah and
Yang Sun spending time together they
seem to have moved on from the traumatic
events that took place last year none of
them have boyfriends and they intend to
live like this for the rest of their
lives the movie ends as Dr Jang who is
now completely recovered arrives with
flowers and joins them in their happy
moments Dr friendzone I presume
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching